Kanan is with us in Auburn Alabama hi
Canaan how are you know mode thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up well I was studying at
West Point and and when I went abroad my
senior year I acted a fool and got
myself kicked out before I graduated
Oh Lord you know oh the know the
government about three hundred thousand
dollars and while I was there I also
took out personal loan about $35,000 I
recently got married in May and my wife
she can't work right now because we're
waiting on her green card I bounced
around a few jobs since then and my when
I'm working on now I was on a bad job
but not particularly passion passionate
about it and I'm actually on my way now
to do my orientation for Domino's and
the good delivered pizzas is a side job
but I just I don't know what to do I
have my career path to being an army and
I thought I was gonna figure it out then
but right now I'm just and I feel like
I'm working you know to pay others day
it's kind of taking me a long time I
feel like yeah how old are you 24 show
you you are how close to graduating from
West Point the day before they told Mel
scheme separated oh man I'm so sorry
what a disaster yeah I mean I I'm on in
this day but yeah it's not take
responsibility for that I understand
English yeah you did it but what a mess
the so I am not positive I mean
obviously that is the preeminent
military War College do those college
credits transfer to another college yes
yes actually
transferred them and was able to get my
degree last month
okay that's good news and what I got was
this stupid majors you talk about
because I finally been in the army but
it's in Russian studies okay but that
was the closest thing for you to finish
yes I ended up finishing up with the
same degree I was studying at West Point
right okay but at least you come out
with a degree okay
all right oh my goodness
well I think you know what I'm gonna do
what drew you to Russian studies while
you're in the military what was your
studying it from a military aspect as I
write write and I just fell in love the
language I was originally in math and
econ major but I wanted to go abroad and
learn the languages and hopefully get a
job the government agency after yeah
okay here's a lot we need to do I want
you to pursue international business
with a specialization in Russia and I
want you to learn how to do trade and
how to do deals because you've got these
skills you've got a natural tendency to
business with it me econ and math you've
got the skill set to do that and you've
got this very specialized set of skills
understanding the Russian culture
language and so forth agreed yes yeah I
think that translates to international
business and there is a lot of money
flowing in and out of Russia legal money
not illegal money as you probably
already know and so yeah I would lean
into that and say that's going to be the
salvation of this mess because I you
know you got a really really big hole
here and delivering Domino's pizzas not
gonna get you out of 300 grand well
that's my that's my side job okay and
our day job is my wife I'll work in a
rubber factory okay now making one I'll
make about $15 an hour you know it's
about 30 grand a year okay well I want
you to forgive yourself for your
stupidity and reset your career
and go okay I'm 24 I did a really dumb
thing it's now in the rear view mirror
I'm not a $15 an hour guy
I'm $100,000 a year guy and I'm gonna go
about becoming a specialist in Russian
international business and I'm gonna
find people that work with people in
Russia businesses that interact with
that and I'm gonna go work for them and
I'm gonna make some serious money to get
out of this mess even if you didn't have
this mess that would be what you would
need to do because you've got that
potential and I don't want you to take a
$15 an hour job and that is now your
future in a factory because you had
right right on the cusp of graduating
from one of the world's finest
institutions you did something stupid
that does not need to define your life
it just needs to cause your life to be
redirected is that okay yeah yeah I
think my biggest thing is just not
really you know my purpose was serving
the army and now since then I've just
kind of been wandering about yep and
it's time to get a new and brother you
know not having a purpose sucks doesn't
it I'm sitting here trying to give you a
new one because I listen
it's an other than the dumb thing you
did you don't get to the final cut the
final day at West Point if you're stupid
you're not an ignorant you're not an
unintelligent person okay you don't get
there it's not possible it's too tough
am I wrong yeah okay you did a dumb
thing with that that doesn't make you
unintelligent it makes you a smart guy
who did a dumb thing I can be put my
name on that list I'm the smart guys
done a lot of dumb things in my life
so put it in the rearview mirror and
let's reset our purpose we're not going
that way okay where are we going
there's got to be a different adventure
and it doesn't mean that you are doomed
to a life of slavery next time I talk to
you a little more hope in your voice a
little more energy in your voice and I
want you fired up and why
about where you're going because that's
the next step in your life brother and
you're not getting out of this debt with
Domino's Pizza and $15 besides that it'd
be a waste of your life you're too sharp
there's too much good you can still do
and you can have some fun with the with
the skill set you've got and you may
even be able to get involved in policy
and some other stuff in the government
position you don't have to graduate from
West Point to use a you know you use
your skillset in a think tank in DC
somewhere so you know don't camp on the
backside of the desert here too long my
brother you've got stuff to do
and you got a mess to clean up too but
you got stuff to do you got potential
don't don't don't sell that out so your
hope for the future matters proverbs
says Hope deferred makes the heart sick
but when desire comes it is the tree of
life ah there we go this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]